[Musique]
avec nous François-Xavier Lacasse et les
professeurs la faculté de pharmacie de
l'Université de Montréal consultant
indépendant de développement de
médicaments bonsoir Monsieur Lacasse
bonsoir à vous alors le groupe
Mitsubishi on le disait là unique
actionnaire de médicaments justifie sa
décision en disant que c'était pas
viable de continuer à investir dans la
commercialisation pourquoi c'était quoi
les problèmes
je vais vous répondre pour tout le monde
même hier soir quand j'ai appris la
nouvelle j'ai appelé des collègues à moi
qui sont qui travaillent de proches ou
de loin avec médicago et eux ont appris
en même temps que nous donc c'est sûr
que c'est très difficile à expliquer on
s'y attendait pas à présent quand on
prend l'information disponible qu'on a
eu dans les journaux aujourd'hui on voit
que c'est plus ou moins multifactoriel
c'était pas vraiment comme vous venez de
dire au niveau des perspectives de
marché pour le vaccin et aussi il parle
et je pense aussi que c'est important de
cette transition entre une compagnie en
recherche qui est une compagnie de
découverte de molécules comme médicaago
et la transition au niveau commercial
fabrication commerciale mais je pense
que d'essayer de trouver une réponse
toute simple de façon monolithique c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça on a
plusieurs hypothèses le fait que le
vaccin contre la covid-19 de médicaments
est arrivée après ce des géants fizer
moderna est-ce que c'est le retard
est-ce que c'est l'efficacité du vaccin
médico qui pourrait lui avoir
éventuellement oui et non toutes ces
réponses c'est vrai que comme vous le
signaler mais escargot et là c'est
arrivé en guillemets plus tard que les
compétiteurs on sait déjà que fizer et
moderna dominer le marché astrozeneca
aussi en avoir du beaucoup mais on va
dire qu'il y avait quand même deux gros
compétiteurs qui étaient sur le marché
quand elle est vous savez on parle
exemple actuellement du vaccin d'évalent
on voit mais par contre il y a
énormément de publicités qui disent que
même les vaccins conventionnels les
premiers qui sont sortis pour la covid
ont quand même une certaine efficacité
face à ceux-là donc est-ce que c'est
l'efficacité en tant que tel du vaccin
du cobifène de médicaments qui fait qui
a fait défaut moi je ne suis pas sûr de
ça je pense que c'est pas suffisant
comme réponse bon à partir du moment où
on sait que l'entreprise va faire mais
ses portes ce sont c'est la suite qui
nous intéresse 300 emplois qui seront
perdus à Québec avec cette fermeture
monsieur la casse est-ce que vous
craignez une expertise une en fait une
perte d'expertise locale
c'est une excellente question moi je
tiens à signaler que selon ma conception
des choses aussi médicaago est une
compagnie qui est une plateforme
technologique unique pour la fabrication
des médicaments biologiques avec les
plantes au départ on sait qui ont
fabriqué avec les œufs donc qui
fabriquent leur médicament avec les œufs
donc on s'est vraiment que c'est une
technologie qui est une unique au Québec
donc cette perte de main d'oeuvre cette
perte d'expertise je sais que le Québec
je vais la garder donc moi j'ai pas
vraiment de souci que tous ces gens-là
vont réussir à se replacer de façon
relativement je dirais facilement dans
le marché actuel donc il y aurait de la
demande pour leur expertise dans le
marché local qu'est-ce qui pourrait
arriver de des brevets des installations
médicaments va vendre les actifs qui lui
restent là entre autres l'usine de
Québec c'est 44000 pieds carrés bourrés
technologies ça coûtait 245 millions à
construire et aujourd'hui le
gouvernement nous dit on est confiant de
trouver des solutions on a espoir de
trouver un repreneur est-ce que vous
pensez que dans la dynamique du marché
là des pharmas ici il y a un repreneur
possible
moi je dirais pourquoi pas oui parce que
là on a ce qu'on appelle des excusez-moi
je connais pas le terme en français en
anglais on dit des assets donc on parle
vraiment
des actifs excusez-moi on a une on a une
compagnie qui est montée comme vous
dites qui est prête à faire de la
production on sait que dernièrement il y
a énormément de compagnie qui se sont
installés au Québec on pense à moderna
on pense aussi que un investissement de
125 millions on pense à résilience qui
est par son Bosson qui s'est installé à
Toronto donc je suis pas vraiment
inquiet pour je dirais les locaux en
tant que tel sur toutes les locaux sont
déjà fabriqués ils sont déjà pris on ne
parle pas de coquille vide donc non je
suis pas vraiment inquiet non plus pour
la suite des choses plutôt persuadé qui
va avoir preneur parce qu'on parle
vraiment d'une usine qui était prête à
faire donc la production de médicaments
on parle pas d'une usine de recherche et
développement
rassurants monsieur Lacasse parce que
vous savez on a des mauvais souvenirs de
ce qui s'est passé autour de 2010 là on
avait une vague de fermeture de pharma
au Québec en particulier dans la région
de Montréal le plus grand plusieurs
grands laboratoire qui avait fermé leur
porte est-ce que la fermeture de Chicago
c'est un accident c'est un cas isolé ou
est-ce que ça traduit un malaise ou des
difficultés dans l'industrie au Québec
au Canada
je suis peut-être rassurant mais par
contre j'ai pas de boule de cristal
parce que si je me remettais hier soir à
la maison ou même moment j'avais aucun
aucun
fermer mais moi je ne pense pas il y a
aussi le fait qu'en 2010 oui mais il y a
le il y a eu un changement de paradigme
le marché a changé le modèle
pharmaceutique a changé aussi donc c'est
peut-être aussi dans cette vague là
qu'en 2010 qui a énormément d'image
durée de fermeture ou de changement de
site de fabrication si je regarde le
marché à l'heure actuelle pharmaceutique
le marché va très très bien c'est encore
une excellente entreprise qui fonctionne
très bien moi en étant professeur je
vois que tous les tous nos étudiants
sont placés il y a pas vraiment du
chômage donc moi je suis je dirais
plutôt optimiste pour l'avenir donc il y
en a de la recherche du développement de
la commercialisation il y a de l'argent
pour appuyer ça aussi en ce moment
monsieur Lacaze
tout à fait il y a énormément d'argent
ne pas oublier que on a eu comme je
viens de dire des usines installés il y
a moderna qui vient à Montréal il y a
peut-être des choses politiques
là-dedans mais il y a quand même une
raison pour laquelle on vient de
Montréal à cause du vivier à cause du
bassin à cause de la formation que les
gens peuvent avoir en développement de
médicaments ce qui est extrêmement
intéressant le Québec est extrêmement
bien en plus placé pour la découverte de
nouvelles molécules donc pour ensuite
engranger un développement préliminaire
précoce pour entrer dans les différentes
phases cliniques de développement le
Québec est très bien placé là-dedans
alors on s'accroche à cet espoir
monsieur la casse merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là je vous remercie bonne journée à
vous pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]